Sogo is a very very simple game in terms
of the rules but it's very difficult
computationally there's an enormous
depth of complexity that comes out of
the very simple rules which is I think
part of what makes people love it so
much as a game so to understand why it's
hard for computers I guess you have to
go back a whole bunch and talk about
just how computers play games in general
these sort of turn-based strategy games
or that kind of thing and start with
something easy like knots and crosses
the sake of internationalization yes
tic-tac-toe I like knots and crosses has
a name because it's descriptive you know
but whatever yeah we're going to look at
noughts and crosses as a game and I'm
going to keep calling that I apologize
but you don't have to apologize I just
what I just want to make sure people if
people understand what was right right
right right
that's all so I'm talking about this
game where you draw you're up to Thorpe
and then one person you know goes here
and one person goes there and so on and
you alternate placing noughts and
crosses and you have to get three in a
row to explain knots and crosses we
should play it an even simpler game so
the idea of the game is we're going to
take it in turns to choose left or right
and I'm going to try and get the highest
number possible and you're going to try
to get the lowest number possible
it starts off my turn so if I choose
left for example it goes down to here
and then it's your turn and you get to
choose left or right and then which
number it ends up on is the outcome of
the game so I want the highest number
possible which is seven you want the
lowest number possible which is one
failing that I'd prefer the five to
three this is a perfect information game
what's the difference what's what's an
imperfect information right right so so
a perfect information game is just a
game where all of the players have all
of the relevant information so this is
like that knots and crosses is like that
chess go these sorts of games you do get
games that are not like that for example
poker there's hidden information you
can't see each other's hands so
you have to if you want to write
something that's going to play those
types of games obviously it has to work
differently to take into account that
uncertainty the question is should I
choose left or right and how do I make a
principled decision now I want the seven
so in principle I should be going this
way right you would think I want to
steer towards the seven but on the other
hand at this point it's your choice
you're not going to choose the seven
because I know you want the low number
you're going to choose the one so I find
choosing this node I'm effectively
choosing the one because I can predict
you'll do that whereas if I choose the
right then your choice is between a
three and a five so you are going to
choose three which is better than the
one so I should go right I'm trying to
maximize the minimum value yeah I'm
trying to make it so that the best
choice available to you is as bad as
possible for you and as good as possible
for me so this is this is called minimax
because I'm trying to minimize the macro
you're trying to minimize the maximum
I'm trying to maximize the minimum if
you see out of me yeah and then purely
based upon who goes first as to who wins
this one right right yeah this is
absolutely unfair game yeah I start off
saying I want that I want the seven so
maybe I should go left to get the seven
right that's one thing I could look for
the highest possible payoff and try and
steer towards it that seems like a
reasonable way of playing the game not
on something this simple where you can
see it obviously fails but in a more
complex game you might think that look
for the best outcome and try and steer
towards it yeah but you've gotta bear in
mind your opponent is doing away from it
or I could look at it and say ah that's
the one I definitely want to avoid the
one so I can't possibly steer left I'm
trying to avoid the bad outcome so I
should go right or you could look at it
and say okay how about this entire tree
what's the average here what's the
average goodness of steering left or
right if you take an average on seven
and one yep aren't you going to get you
get four four because that's simplest
one say if you take the average of three
and five
you also get four so in this case
they're the same does that mean they're
both equally good well no because one of
them I end up with one and one of the
minor was a three so so we're basically
saying here okay there are different
ways to evaluate the choices that you
make yeah most of them don't
most amount any good okay but there is
one way that works which is basically
what we did which is mimics and so it's
a recursive function so let's try a more
complicated game I'm going to generate
some random numbers just using Python to
get us a list and then shuffle that list
and there it is
so I'm just going to draw the trees
before it was obvious that I kind of
designed those choices to make a point
here it's random so it's a real game now
in many ways a better game than not some
crosses because somebody's can actually
win
probably whenever you see a tree in
computer science you should always kind
of be thinking about recursion which
you've done a video on before rights
amigos what I dive back into this same
piece of code because a tree has this
kind of fractal structure where ideally
you want to have an algorithm where you
do the same thing and every part of the
tree and then you can have one algorithm
that processes the whole tree so the
problem with recursion a problem with
recursion is infinite recursion where
you have this sort of loop of nested
stuff that never ends you need a
degenerate case you need a case where
the answer is easy and in this case it's
the bottom right so if we are at the
bottom first move by the maximizing
player second move by the minimizing
player third move by the maximizing
player so here which way should I go I
should go with whichever one is bigger
it's the seven right so we can
effectively call this a seven it's not
the end of the game but the value of
this node is effectively seven because
if this player directs us to there the
game will end with a seven so you can do
that in each case so this one is a five
because that's the bigger one this one
it's a three and this one it's the six
so now these nodes which before you
couldn't do because they didn't have any
values now these look a lot like the
nodes below so here now we're being the
minimizing player
so this will be a five and this will be
a three and now we're being the
maximizing player again who wants to go
for the five so you can see here then as
the maximizing player the best score I
can get is the five that's assuming that
we're all playing by the same
decision-making stress right it helps
that it's the optimal decision-making
structure in this situation okay but you
don't have to make the best choice right
if you make a mistake I have values on
all the other nodes of the tree I can
make probably do even better but the way
that min/max works is you end up with
the making the best possible player you
could make as bad as possible and you're
trying to do the same to me this is a
game you can play with your friends it's
a it's a huge fun for everyone
if you can do min max in your head and
obviously if you have you can put 16
numbers at the bottom 32 whatever but
you'll notice of course the more numbers
you have at the bottom the more work
you've got to do to figure out all of
these into intervening nodes and it's
tractable for some real games that
people play like noughts and crosses so
I could say I'm going to try it so if we
take a game like notes and grasses
tic-tac-toe which is so simple that
human beings reliably learn to play it
optimally you start off at the beginning
your notes you have nine choices right
because you can go one two three four
five six seven eight those your options
now it's the crosses turn and you're
there you have eight options because one
of the squares is taken so one two six
five six seven eight and here there's a
and you see just quickly this becomes
ridiculous but no game of noughts and
crosses lasts more than nine turns
guaranteed you run out of spaces we go
along slow I'm only going to fill in
part of the tree now the point is what's
the degenerate case because we're not
trying to get numbers so what you do is
you say this isn't going to be right but
let's just say as an exam
for a moment yes said it's that so it's
a win for knots so if we're playing
Nords we give this board a score of 1
because we say 1 we've won excellent a
different board where the crosses have a
win that's a minus 1 because I really
don't want that and then any state where
the game is over
but nobody's won it's surprisingly
difficult
I accidentally want it this is how hard
this game is there what what can I do
all I do is win so so you're ok then it
says the drawing that's a draw so that's
a zero if it's your turn and you have a
move that can win then that board state
is it win and therefore you just
propagate that up indefinitely exactly
the same way as you would before yes so
you can see how you can plot this out
and it's much too big to actually do but
if you write a computer program to do it
it's not difficult it's a short program
doesn't take long to run and noughts and
crosses is a solved game right so let's
draw the thing for chess how much paper
if we go yeah it's this drawer chest
okay yeah I'm not gonna draw chess while
you're not going to draw chess while you
know to come be that much more difficult
kind of yeah so we need more paper we
need a lot more paper to draw chess and
the issue is the thing the thing you can
see the thing that's so different here
between the simple game the very simple
game and noughts and crosses is this
thing called branching factor which is
basically at each little node how many
branches does the tree have simple in
this game it's two here we have two
choices
here we have two choices here we have
two choices you always have two choices
this is a longer game it has more turns
but the branching factor is still two
every turn you have two choices you can
make in noughts and crosses okay firstly
it's more complicated because the
branching factor is higher secondly it's
complicated because it changes in the
first turn you have nine choices the
second time
eight and so on so the branching factor
actually reduces as the game goes on
which is one of the things that makes it
easier to compute so let's think about
it let's think about chess then in chess
the very beginning let's say you're
white you're about to start you've got
eight pawns you can move you can move
them forward one so that's eight
possibilities or you could move it
forward two
so that's 16 plus you have two knights
that are allowed to move because they
can jump so each of those has two it's
another four I think it's 20
I really play chess but I think I think
it's 20 I think you start off with 20 so
I'd be drawing one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
all the way up to 20 and then as the
game goes on much like in noughts and
crosses the number of possible moves
available to you legal moves varies
right so presumably first it goes oh
yeah
as the game opens up early on you get
more moves available because you've got
sort of more space and things can things
can move to several different you know
positions and all that kind of thing and
then past a certain point it starts to
go down again because pieces get
captured and when obviously when you
have only a few pieces on the board you
don't have as many moves available to
you but on average when people play
chess I think the average branching
factor is about 35 but chess games
generally go longer than nine turns
right so when you're calculating the
number of nodes in your tree every turn
you're multiplying by the branching
factor and that quickly gets completely
unmanageable so you can't just mid
maxilla chess like this it's
computationally completely infeasible
which is why chess was considered such a
big milestone for a long time if you
could make a computer that could play
chess you know you're not just doing
this very trivial brute-forcing thing
like you're doing for noughts and
crosses you know for a computer could
play chess it
really have to be thinking right you can
see a cow here we were taking the end
states where we knew the value of the
game and then propagating backwards in
time from there to give value to these
board states that we didn't know the
value of before the problem is there you
have to go right from the very end of
the game which in chess you can't do
this there's just too many possibilities
so you need some way of giving boards
values that isn't just propagating
backwards from the possibilities from
known and you know checkmate states and
luckily in chess there's a lot of things
you can do about that the most obvious
one is just counting up the pieces you
just say well a pawn is worth you know
one point and a queen is worth nine you
do some analysis of how games tend to go
and you you try and figure out how good
the pieces you have left are basically
and the position of them obviously is
important but you can get a good it's a
good heuristic it's a good approximation
to just add up the scores of the pieces
and say well you know this team has both
their Knights and still has their queen
and this this only has one night and is
lost their queen so it's really obvious
that this team is winning and therefore
that's a good stay to the board and you
don't need to be able to see all the way
to the endgame to know that it's a good
stay to the board so the point is
because chess is branching factor is so
much higher you can't do this thing
where you work backwards from the end
States the branching factor is too high
you have to start from where you are and
look forwards and say okay
hypothetically if I went this way what
would that look like
what boards would that allow me to get
to and then if from there I went here
how would that look and so on you don't
know whether you're heading towards a
win or not and this is where the
heuristics come in is that they let you
put some kind of numbers on these notes
like you know do I still have my Queen
in this note and that should guide you
towards winning positions because there
tend to be more winning positions in
situations where you have your queen but
it's always a heuristic you they're not
the the chess AI is not seeing forwards
in time to a win they're seeing forwards
a certain distance and seeing that it's
a good
to be in according to and it obviously
it's not just what they have on the
board like that's an oversimplification
there's a lot of different heuristics
but the point is you're going to have to
evaluate a very very large number of
boards so you want something you can
compute quickly because the more boards
you can evaluate the further ahead you
can look and therefore the better you
can play even in this game if you're
playing with someone and you can think
more moves ahead than them that gives
you a huge advantage because you can
force them into a into a situation where
the best move available to them is quite
bad and they didn't think to steer away
from that because they didn't look as
far ahead as you what this number means
is if I go here and then play perfectly
from that point on what's the worst
score I'd end up getting this algorithm
assumes that your opponent is always
going to play the best move that's
available to them because you're always
prepared for the worst possible scenario
so you're only ever pleasantly surprised
chess is a different ball game it's got
more complicated maneuvers it's got
different ways of branching as well as
larger branches so how does this all
feed back into our original point of go
looks pretty straightforward to me right
okay go right let's draw go okay we're
going to need more paper is there also
significantly larger universe to put
that paper in go is difficult for a lot
of reasons actually the first reason
that makes go difficult is the branching
factor is very high it's generally more
than 200 compared to chess is 35 so
every turn there are at least 200
possible moves you could be making and
so if you imagine me drawing this tree
with 200 come on then most draw it all
right 301 I begin it I'm going to run
out of pen to see what I'm gonna go in
between so six thirty nine forty you
know what I think life's too short Rob
yeah no you're right yeah this margin is
too too narrow to contain so um it's not
going to happen right it's not gonna
happen
and what's more even you know it wasn't
going to happen with noughts and crosses
but you can do it in a computer you
can't do that with go we can't do that
with chess even and you really can't do
it with go and so even a lot of the
cleverness of tree search and like
pruning and all of the really neat
algorithmic improvements people have
made for ways of navigating these trees
that allow this type of old-fashioned AI
to be extremely good at playing chess
and better than any human at this point
that approach is not going to work with
go and was never going to work with go
and so go became the great on the goth
past tense
go became the great the great milestone
right after chess go was the big one so
right where we were going with wise it's
hard the branching factor is huge that's
one thing but also you don't have a lot
of the tricks that you have with chess
you can glance at a chess board as I
said and just add up the pieces and say
well this you know white is probably
winning or black is probably winning in
go that's not the case in the middle of
a game of go between two good players
other good players could not necessarily
tell you who's winning right now because
the specifics of who's winning depends
very sensitively on the precise layout
of the pieces it's not just a matter of
who has more stones on the board or who
has more territory or who has more
points or anything like that it's sort
of an emergent property of the pattern
of the layout which means you don't have
these easy shortcuts you can use to
evaluate a position not only are there
10 times as many possibilities to search
there's no obvious way to even Carol if
a position is good once you once you're
looking at it which is well this is why
this is so impressive what's been
achieved by alphago
to beat the best human players at a game
where all of the standard tricks of the
trade won't work and you have to really
try something new hidden melty display
that tracks where you're looking and
various other things so it overlays and
this can represent the other paddle so
we've got two objects with the identical
interfaces want to represent